but he was a big man and myself I call
us people of size yeah but we understand
that the fat activism is a little much
it's getting a little much and I agree
with that I understand that uh people
are upset no nobody should be abusing
fat but you shouldn't be walking around
and you know abusing them but we can't
do it what does that look like walking
around my act you know in the 80s and
90s fat women just kind of beauty yeah
fat women were just abused like people
pointed to me like look at this fat
[__] right there are people that want
to go back to that because they're
monsters right but uh we can't demand
that the entire world remake themselves
for the fat people but I would say if
you had it look yeah if you put the fat
consumer forward on in an airline oh I
think that's that consumer is fun if you
put the [__] super on the Forefront
yeah everyone's having a better time
right a little extra leg room I I don't
need law I don't need more leg room I
need more width right you know what I'm
saying on a plane seat you're telling me
that wouldn't be nice if you're some
skinny piece of [__] to be honest I
really really open up those [__] I
think that that if a fat person were to
design a plane yeah you would even the
thin people would have a lot more fun oh
a lot more fun it's a good point the
airlines would lose some money they'd
lose a lot of money
would be the healthiest option the fact
that there's a cookie with no cream
involved there's no chocolate chip they
give us that glorified wafer and they
tell us that's that's dessert well
you're in first class I'm In First Class
it's better it's much better it's the
only luxury I'll never give up I will
live on the street but I will never give
up the first class you get on First
Class you're like oh you think this is
gonna be the best flight of my life and
you're like oh they treat you like a
human being yes and that's it that's
what first class is it's just being
treated like a human being when you were
in the back of the plane which I was for
years in a middle seat wherever I could
be is there anything worse no then when
you are uh on the aisle and the guy it
feels like fully full fully full plane
yeah and they're like this plane is
mostly full and you're like [__]
someone's gonna sit here
it's like it's already done you're like
oh my God people are they've [__] the
flight attendants are putting everything
up you're like is this happening is this
really gonna happen and then you see
someone rushed on the plane and they're
elated they made their flight last
second and then the second they see
they're sitting next to you all that Joy
is gone they're like I should have just
missed it and I had an aisle to myself I
sat once on a plane this is I'm not even
kidding yeah with two of the fattest
guys
in a row
it was to the point where and we were in
by the way yeah in a row that was like
you know there's first class and then
there's like the the you know Comfort
plus whatever it is we were in one of
those first rows so the people all all
looked at us as they were walking back
every like an attraction at the zoo
every single person looked at that row
where it is like God damn it look
because it never happens we have three
huge guys it was three big dudes they're
like earn an extra cook if you can tell
us where his thighs end and his begin
yeah
and that's one mass of Flesh not one of
us looked at each other
and not one of us said anything to each
other and all of our faces were
rage oh dude I've actually been there
when I get a fat guy next to me I'm like
the airline should step in what the [__]
is this the government should step I'll
turn into what Marxist right now the
government step in look if there was a
child in first class they gotta switch
the fatty in the middle seat with that
[__] like with that kid trust my kid
I hate by the way I hate children you
should never be allowed hate them should
never be I hate them on their iPads yeah
I hate them so much I hate the attitudes
they already have 100 telling the ho
like telling the flight attendant like
uh just ordering them around away you
would be like embarrassing it's horrible
more apple juice yeah it's disgusting I
hate when a family's in first class and
I go oh all of you or I've my family was
never in first class no so when I see an
entire Rich family In First Class how
much despicable kids have to be you want
to get them Comfort plus fine right I
cannot be in first if I was a rich
parent I would just throw the kids in
the back you go guys have some fun there
be independent right do some stuff you
know whatever you want to do this is
your taste of what reality this is
reality man for four hours at a time
you'll get it and never again yeah
otherwise it's like it's it's it's
absolutely ridiculous